hi everybody I'm Walter Benes yak and
this is top five before we get into
today's topic I just wanted to say thank
you so much for the gigantic response
that we got from last week's top 5 best
nostalgia critic episodes we were
trending that's crazy the feedback has
been awesome so thank you for voting
watching and sticking with Doug and the
nostalgia critic for ten great years now
there's a new Marvel movie out you may
have heard of it it's a little feature
called spider-man homecoming and it's
getting amazing reviews including one
from yours truly however that got me
thinking
most Marvel movies that are out nowadays
are at least passable but that wasn't
always the case there are some immense
thinkers out there and now is the
perfect time to remind us all just how
far we've come just to be clear we're
talking about all Marvel live-action
movies here every one of them is fair
game
long before Marvel Studios created a
cinematic universe that everyone for the
most part likes movies about their
characters we're still of course being
made while some of those films are
generally liked and even loved there are
a decent amount that are just awful our
favorite characters weren't getting the
respect they deserve and the quality of
these films show that let's learn from
these mistakes and keep this Marvel
movie train rolling smooth well mostly
moving smooth these are the top 5 worst
Marvel movies number 5 spider-man 3 if
you go back and check out our worst
comic book movie episode of awesome
comics I picked this film as the worst
upon reinvestigation there are movies
that are clearly worse than this one but
I definitely hate spider-man 3 the most
trying to describe this plot makes me
nauseous but I'll give it my best shot
Peter Parker and Harry Osborn finally
clash over the death of Harry's father
Norman the former friends battle until
Harry is seriously injured and gets
amnesia for getting that Peter is
spider-man and what happened with his
father meanwhile an alien symbiote
crashes to earth and attaches itself to
Peter spider-man suit initially he gains
great strength from it but the longer he
wears it the more aggressive he becomes
this is made worse when MJ and Peter's
start having problems in the
relationship while all this is going on
Flint Marko an escaped con
Vick is involved in an accident that
transforms his body into living sand
taking the name sand man Marco attempts
to steal enough money to pay for his
sick daughter's life-saving surgery it
is also revealed that he is actually the
man who killed Peters Uncle Ben and this
causes spider-man to go on a revenge
fueled hunt with his black suit in tow
there's more a lot more but I think you
get it I think what makes me the most
angry about this failure is that we
should have had two or three more movies
from this spider-man even though I hated
this movie the more time went on I was
still very excited when they announced
spider-man 4 I thought the series of the
whole was good enough to rebound from
this but as we know it never did
spider-man 3 destroy the franchise in a
similar way to how Batman and Robin did
except this time the reboot came three
years sooner I loved the first film so
much and wanted to see this all continue
but these screwed things up so badly
that confidence was lost Raimi had
problems with Sony on this one and that
eventually led to his departure from
four and the downfall of his version of
the wall-crawler I'm going to put some
dirt in your eye everything that needs
to be said about how bad this is has
pretty much already been said James
Franco's weird performance I know that
they make you suffer make him wish he
were dead first we attack his heart
strawberries emo Peter nothing
[Music]
the worst casting ever in Topher Grace
as Eddie Brock and the horrible misuse
of venom oh my spider-sense is tingling
if you know what I'm talking about
and how this movie was stuffed with so
much crap not a bad person
just had bad mark I know that face that
means moving on to number four number
four Elektra I had avoided Elektra
before watching it for this list and yes
it's very very bad but not quite number
one worst material like I was expecting
after being resurrected following her
death in 2003 daredevil Elektra is taken
under the wing of martial arts masters
stick and taught a new discipline where
she learns among other things
precognition
she is kicked out of the order when she
cannot let go of her rage now Elektra is
a legendary assassin for hire who was
very good at her job
when she's hired to kill two targets she
is sent to a home on an island to wait
for those names to be delivered to her
while there she befriends a man and his
daughter only to realize later that they
are the targets she was hired to kill
she spares them but when the hand
arrives to finish the job himself
Elektra must protect the very people she
was about to be paid to kill we got an
Electra movie years before we ever got a
Wonder Woman movie I still don't get
that Hey look who's playing the leader
of the hand you stole mine
his name's even better Master Roshi
this whole film just feels pointless was
anyone asking for an Electra movie it
just ends up looking like a bad x-men
knockoff with a random powers of the
hands warriors
what the hell was that
anyway the movie is varied by the
numbers it seems like minimum effort was
put in to make it interesting
even the performances reflect this no
one stands out even Terence Stamp a
stick just blends in with this dull
story but hey if you like white sheets
flying in the air or the end of the
shining maybe you'll be into this but
overall it's a pointless film that was
spun off from a really bad one
speaking of which number three
daredevil when I first saw this movie I
was only 14 years old and I realized he
didn't then that it sucked years later
it's gotten even worse Matt Murdock is
the son of a troubled boxer who was
involved in an accident that leaves him
blind but gives him superhuman
capabilities in his other senses after
his father is murdered Matt later
becomes the vigilante daredevil his
nemesis the kingpin is a crime lord who
controls much of New York and wants
daredevil dead at any cost when an
assassin named bullseye enters the fray
Matt seems to have met his match as the
kingpin continues to destroy lives
including the family of his love
interest Elektra first things first we
have to talk about the real star of this
film Colin Farrell and bullseye first
was a warning Padre the Green Wave
let's bring on the boy he is literally
playing a cartoon character and is by
far the best part of the movie one of
the reasons I was weary about athlete
playing Batman was because of his
performance in this movie I mean look at
this face it just screams terror at
least he got some practice murdering in
for his future as Batman not the bad guy
yeah okay everything involving Elektra
is also pretty damn dumb from smelling
her to fighting in front of little kids
at the park this came off as fake as
Jennifer Garner's green contacts plan
daredevil dates itself with its overuse
of cool angry rock music from the early
2000s maybe not overuse abuse is a
better word
[Music]
jon favreau got to play foggy here maybe
this was when he saw a superhero movie
up close and thought to himself yeah I
could do this shit way better
I am man what ball the most damning
thing about the daredevil movie is that
it was done so much better as a Netflix
show the first season is probably the
strongest I've seen from a superhero TV
series looking back on this after
watching that has made this movie an
even bigger joke than it already was
stay stay with me yeah stay we have two
more movies to get through number two
faint four stick I think what's most
embarrassing about this movie's
placement in the top five is that it
just came out two years ago we should be
past this maybe one day a movie will be
made about the making of this movie now
that I'd like to see interdimensional
travel has been cracked by college
students I think after Reed Richards
Johnny Storm Victor Von Doom and Ben
Grimm transport themselves to another
dimension things go wrong Victor is
seemingly killed while Johnny sister sue
tried bringing the survivors home
however in the madness they're all
involved in an event that gives them
superpowers with most of them now
working for the government the company
funding the original project decides to
return to the other dimension to
discover its secrets upon arriving they
see that Victor is alive and bring him
back to earth but Victor spots now only
go towards serving one purpose
destroying the world with a giant Sky
laser beam thing the first two fantastic
four movies weren't very good okay they
were bad but compared to this mess well
they're still bad but not as bad after
dim over here this movie is a big
cluster of bullcrap if you know anything
about the behind the scenes drama
surrounding this thing you know it was
destined to fail
we'll start with director Josh Trank's
now infamous tweet a year ago I had a
fantastic version of this and it would
have received great reviews he'll
probably never see it that's reality
though you can tell right there that
there was obviously a ton of fundamental
problems and disagreements between Trank
and Foxx the movie ended up having a lot
of reshoots which resulted in an uneven
film to say the least
no figures only do we have to judge this
movie as it is though and as it is it's
awful there's nothing wrong with dark
superhero stories but they have to be
done well and appropriate for the
characters they're using I don't think
the Fantastic Four are called for a dark
and gritty reboot it's an interesting
idea and definitely an unexpected way of
presenting this story but the Fantastic
Four should be fun and bright and unlike
the first two films it can be done the
right way
funnily enough the signature tone of the
MCU would probably be pitch perfect for
a Fantastic Four movie right now but as
we've seen Fox and Marvel slash Disney
do not play well with each other as much
of a miracle as it was for Sony and
Marvel to share spider-man it's even
more unlikely that Fox will do anything
similar with Marvel anytime soon for
whatever reason they will not let go of
these characters and with the rumors of
a sequel floating around this superhero
quartet most likely won't be done right
anytime soon alien
it's been faster
yes it is four down one to go and the
number one worst Marvel movie is luck
[Music]
question Lulu Howard is a duck from duck
world who was unwittingly transported to
our earth and can't find a way back
while here he befriends a rock singer
named Beverly and together they try to
figure out a plan to return him home one
scientist dr. Jenning attempts just that
he accidentally transfers an evil alien
into his body as he gains more power and
attempts to transport more of his own
kind to earth it's up to Howard and
Beverly to stop it yes from executive
producer George Lucas comes the worst
Marvel movie ever released you're
probably not surprised but Howard the
Duck is the most bizarre unusual little
movie making Howard the Duck feature in
1986 was ambitious no more mr. nice duck
[Music]
no one laughed at a master of quack fool
I still can't tell what demographic they
were aiming for with this movie it feels
like a kid's film for a lot of it but
then we have duck boobs duck condoms and
then Howard slash Lea Thompson almost
sex scene look anyway where will it all
leave marriage kids a house in the
suburbs let's just face it it's fate
No then we had Tim Robbins GGG basically
the same thing it's just a baffling
motion picture that you have to see to
understand how frickin weirded it duck
man well he's right play us out Howard
[Music]
alright that's enough of that there you
go marvel at its worst it's a good thing
that most of these kinds of movies are
in the past and the future continues to
look bright for most of Marvel's
properties just in case we ever veer off
course though filmmakers will do well to
heat these bad films as a warning of
what can happen even with our most
beloved characters I want to hear what
you guys think what is your least
favorite Marvel movie what do you want
me to cover next on the show leave a
comment and let me know for more content
like my spider-man homecoming review
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome Walter like my
new Facebook page facebook.com slash
awesome walter b and follow me on
twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future come
back next week is we get animated with a
very special spidey series
[Music]
you